okay the Trump administration may be the
death of common sense it may be the
death of America as a steward of the
environment it may be the death of
critical thinking it could be the end of
many things under the Trump
administration but it's also in a way
the end of satire and parody I've
already talked about Saturday Night Live
Saturday Night Live's job and they do it
really well is very tough because the
real world has become almost
indistinguishable from the most extreme
Saturday Night Live parodies that they
can come up with under the presidency of
Donald Trump and Trump advisor Kellyanne
Conway has now said seemingly with no
trace of irony or satire whatsoever
about the Roy Moore sexual assault
allegations that anyone in elected
office who committed sexual assault
should resign and of course her boss the
President of the United States committed
sexual assault and he's the president
and she's certainly not calling for his
resignation at least not directly she
kept being asked by ABC's Martha Raddatz
should Roy Moore step aside and she
refused to answer that question but
instead did say that she's been clear
that anyone who commits sexual assault
should resign let's build up to it
here's a first clip of Kellyanne Conway
no reference to the Bowling Green
massacre in this clip but she did talk
about other things for more let's bring
in counselor to the president and one of
his top advisors Kellyanne Conway her
voice among those advising Donald Trump
as he decides whether to reject Roy
Moore and good morning Kellyanne The
Washington Post story is now three days
old you've had time to digest it time to
look through it do you have any doubt
about the veracity of those accusations
I said very early in this process that
the conduct as described should
disqualify anyone from serving in public
office and I'll stand by that the
president and others in the Republican
Party have made clear that if the
allegations are true this man should
step aside but I've gone farther than
that and I've reflected something the
vice president said as well which is
everybody should know that conduct is
disqualifying right so it's all
disqualifying conduct but what about
resignations and here's the big-time one
again no trace of irony when Kellyanne
Conway says anyone should step down very
explicit here I denounce that conduct
and if the allegations are true he
should step aside and if the allegations
are true about a lot of people they
ought to step aside and some of them are
probably holding office let me tell you
what wellyes Kellyanne many of them are
holding office right now one of them is
your boss that's really a statement from
Kellyanne that will really grab you by
the something and make you look really
closely at it she wants to talk about
Bob Menendez Democrat and Bill Clinton
Democrat right what about Donald Trump
what about the current president who has
been accused by endless women of sexual
assault and the bigger question is why
ask Kellyanne Conway anything at this
point right she has absolutely no
internal set of values beyond getting
paid to parrot whatever she's told to
say if we're actually going to be
serious about getting every sexual
assault er out of office you kind of
have to start at the top with Trump
himself and there's a video you can
check it out for yourself and evaluate
the credibility there's video of a woman
using the name Katy Jay who claims that
Donald Trump tied raped and tied to beat
and raped her apparently in that order
although not necessarily also threatened
heard with murder when she was 13 years
old don't take my word for it right
check out the video which I've watched a
couple of times she seems relatively
credible and if you want to write her
off as many of many of the Trump
supporters are doing there's more than a
dozen other women right so if you really
stand by that Kellyanne how can you
ignore the reality that Donald Trump
should be at the top of the list and
this is what I'm talking about when I
say that satire is being killed by the
Trump administration the Saturday Night
Live sketches around these characters
Sarah Huckabee Sanders and Trump himself
and Kellyanne Conway Sean Spicer the
entire thing they're great right they're
brilliant from a comedic perspective but
they're in no way giving you the
impression that it could never actually
be that crazy because it's actually that
crazy it's gotten as crazy
Night Live in the actual real Trump
White House and it's a real problem for
Saturday Night Live in a sense although
hey I'm not criticizing their ability to
put together funny sketches by any means
Kellyanne come on just say that it
applies to Trump as well discuss this
with us on our reddit discussion forum
at david pakman.com slash our IDI di t
we'll take a break and be back right
after this today's program is made
possible in part by Gamefly which is
sort of like netflix for video games
they've got over 8,000 new and classic
games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can also stream games you don't even
need a gaming console or a computer
because you can stream games through
your Amazon fire stick or Roku box and
then use your mobile phone as the
controller you can play as many games as
you want for one monthly fee and if you
find some games you want to keep you can
buy them for a low used price never with
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a 30-day free trial at Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included no contracts and you
can also stream the games I think I
mentioned that you can also rent games
through the mobile app get a free 30 day
trial for david pakman show viewers and
listeners and support our show at
Gamefly offer.com forward slash TDP s